in the year 2030 nine new developments
in virtual reality could give connecting
with someone you fancy a whole new
meaning Facebook already hosts a show
called virtually dating where couples
strap on headsets and virtually spend
time in exotic locations imagine if you
could go on a date without the
commitment of having to actually be
there in person a 21st century romance
or just another way to bash into the
furniture of your ridiculously small
housing pod before you take off your
headset only to remember there's no one
there
alternatively maybe your VR date will go
so well
you'll question why you need a real life
partner in the first place a company in
Japan is already offering men the chance
to marry their favorite anime characters
will you be professing your lifelong
commitment to a 3d hologram in a virtual
chapel if you're a woman the answer may
well be no even though research shows
that people are more likely to open up
to a machine than a person it also shows
that women are less likely to try
virtual reality than men a company's
recent solution turn the headsets pink
it didn't solve the problem if by 2030
nine VR is more widespread could
connecting to your partner emotionally
or physically simply mean digging out
your VR toolkit and plugging one of a
number of hem devices into a USB port or
does the very thought of this make you
want to split up or throw up if looking
the one you love in the eye is more your
thing
you might prefer glasses that you face
analyzing algorithms to scientifically
reveal when someone finds you attractive
a way to make dating less time-consuming
or a virtual slap in the face when you
discover that everyone you're pretty
much definitely sure fancies you doesn't
digital technology is often criticized
for increasing loneliness as people turn
more to their screams for support rather
than each other
however by 2039 we could be using dating
apps to connect with a multitude of
people in a variety of new non romantic
ways
we'll find in a partner to settle down
would be something your parents use to
do either way with nightclubs across the
UK closing down and fewer young people
drinking alcohol it seems like the days
of see you at the bar and having one too
many of what was it again
only to wake up with who are you are
probably numbered so if we're still
going on real dates with real people
will probably need new venues for
example a trampoline park
at home according to a recent report
there's been an overwhelming rise in
trampolining imagine this was where you
meet in a heart I'm very sweaty day in
2039 new kinds of immersive cinema
experiences such as 4d or 5d might also
pave the way for virtual reality films
which would make the cinema the perfect
place for a date in 2039 with friends
partners or anyone in between just like
it's always been
you